mitted access to a distribution either
through samples or through some kind of
noisy queries or something and so it
only gets this kind of skinny pipe and
intuitively if you start with a learning
algorithm it's easier to kind of take
what it does and compress it down into
differentially private output so I think
this is just a very high level intuition
for why tools from learning should be
useful for designing differentially
private algorithms for sort of any task
you want to do and I think so I am NOT a
historian of differential privacy but I
think the first time kind of learning
and differential privacy were connected
was in a work by a lung dork McSherry
and nice IAM where the connection was
made to kind of the statistical queries
learning model it was also developed in
an influential paper by casillas wanna
son leeny see Morse code nikova and
Smith on kick on actually designing
differentially private learning
algorithm so this has been a very well
explored area and may say sort of two
reasons why I think it's important to be
aware of this kind of connection and the
techniques that come out of it so one is
that when you use the sort of techniques
you end up getting sort of powerful
algorithms with very clean and
qualitatively strong guarantees I'll you
know say more specifically what that is
but I think this is a point that
shouldn't be overlooked that in privacy
we don't really know what's possible or
especially when these techniques were
coming out we really didn't know it was
possible and getting these very like
qualitatively clean and strong
statements i think was very important
for clarifying the potential to do
things in this area and also with
respect to the way i'm going to define
the problem in these strong guarantees
learning theoretic techniques are going
to give us kind of nearly optimal
algorithms so i think you know for a
reasonably to find problem when you get
nearly optimal algorithms that means
there's something useful going on so
hopefully i'll sort of convey what the
techniques are and that can lead people
to use them in various other settings so
let me tell you what problem i do want
to solve so i said i'm not inherently
solving a learning problem i want to
solve this problem called private
counting query release so what's a
counting query it's just a I take a
database it's got n records each one of
dfd bit
information about a person and I want to
know what fraction of Records satisfies
some property q any property I want all
right so these by the way are two
important parameters for the talk and is
the number of people each one gets a row
of the database d is the number of bits
per row all right so here's an example
of a query it's satisfied by these three
people but not the first so the answer
is three-fourths all right simple enough
and I don't just want one counting query
that's not very much information what I
want to do is I want to produce some
kind of rich summary of the database so
I want to design some algorithm that
takes a database and some very large
family of queries think of it
conceptually is very large it's sort of
all the queries you might want to ask
and it's going to output some summaries
so I wrote here that it'll output just a
list of answers but really what it's
going to output is just some sort of
algorithm that lets you answer one of
the queries in queue maybe a database
for instance would be a nice thing for
it to do and I'm going to say that it's
accurate if any of the queries in this
set big queue I can get an accurate
answer from the summary all right so the
answers to queries and Q range from zero
to one's life some small parameter alpha
that says how accurate I want the
answers to be and I want this to hold
for every cue alright so notice the way
I've defined the problem it's very
strong so there's no reference to a
distribution I want this to work for
every database I don't assume anything
about the queries except maybe I have
some bound on the number and I want to
be able to accurately estimate the
answer to every query so it's what I
meant when I'm talking about solving
kind of a very strong clean problem and
all right what I want to do is not just
solve it accurately but I want to solve
it in a differentially private way
Katrina gave a very nice tutorial on
this so I'm not going to you know walk
through the definition of differential
privacy again it's not technically so
important for the talk I do want to call
attention to the fact that when i say
differential privacy I always mean this
kind of two parameter epsilon Delta
definition so you can always kind of
adjust what I'm saying for epsilon zero
but for people who kind of you
no the results if anything looks
unfamiliar this might be why all right
this is the problem and you know what do
I want to do to sort of quantify how
well I've solved the problem the two
parameters that I'm interested in are
the amount of data required so you know
this database consists of some let's say
samples from a population I want to know
how many samples I need to collect and I
want to know as a function of various
other parameters like the accuracy the
number of queries the number of
attributes and I'm going to focus mostly
on this especially for the first half of
the talk but I also care a lot about the
running time of the sanitizer that's
going to turn out to be an important
kind of challenging issue for designing
these algorithms right it's the problem
kind of clean enough clear enough all
right so here just a very quick history
of sort of you know the highlights what
you need to know about this problem so
the first thing you try to do is just
take all of your queries write down
their answers and add noise
independently to each answer this is
katrina side kind of the canonical way
people think of of solving a
differential privacy problem and I claim
this is not a great solution because you
know I want to think about answering a
lot of Peary's and the amount of data i
need to to have is going to grow kind of
as the square root of the number of
queries so that's not very good it's not
a great approach to solving the problem
fortunately is very exciting results of
bangla getting raw from about five years
ago now where they showed that you can
get an exponentially better dependence
on a number of queries all right so the
amount of data I need to I need only
grows logarithmically with the number of
queries it has somewhat worse dependence
on the other parameters but the point is
I can now give in a database of size and
I can actually answer exponentially many
queries on the database and this was
sort of the first paper that kind of I
think explicitly connected learning
theory to this problem and there was a
long line of work giving sort of various
important improvements I don't want to
you know ignore them but I just want to
abridge the history of it and jump
forward to what we have now which is the
private multiplicative weights algorithm
so
is a very kind of nice algorithm for
solving this problem it gives good
quantitative guarantees it gives good
qualitative guarantees was introduced in
a paper by heart and Roth bloom and
various kind of variants on the
algorithm have appeared and some of
those variants I'm going to talk about
involve some work that I was a part of
where we sort of put this multiplicative
weights algorithm in kind of a general
framework that makes a very kind of
modular connection to learning
algorithms and also leads to kind of
tighter analysis of the algorithm and
also in in subsequent work having this
general framework has led to sort of
several improvements for special cases
and I think this is kind of where a lot
of the you know sort of the action is in
these problems all right so this is
actually a pretty good kind of summary
of what the talk is going to be about is
basically the slide now of course saying
that i have another summary about the
talk is going to be about so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to
introduce kind of a just a generic
blueprint for how you might solve
private counting query release and it's
a blueprint that we sort of formalized
in a paper with on a pom Gupta and Aaron
Roth and you know so let me tell you you
know me just sort of say how i think is
like an intuitive way to solve these
problems so on the right you have the
raw data it's you know you can't this is
private you know this has to be private
output the data sets behind it and we
have to think about what we can get
through this barrier so maybe a
reasonable thing to do is without even
looking at the database will start with
some very crude guess of what the
database might be presumably we will
fail because why would we be able to do
this and will now kind of send through
the privacy barrier a question will ask
you know is our approximation good for
answering all the queries and cue all
the queries we care about and it
probably won't be so we're going to need
something about the real database we're
going to need some kind of hint anyone
think of what might be a good sort of
hint that we want to get about the
database right
success all right fantastic so I mean if
it's not good for Q there must be some
query it's not good for so I'm going to
try to get a the sanitizer to tell me
some query that I don't answer well and
then given this information I want to
have some clever way of improving my
approximation to the database so I have
some algorithm you that takes the query
in the database so it takes this as
input and it's going to come up with a
slightly better guess of what the
databases hopefully all right and not
surprisingly we're going to repeat
because we're probably still not there
and hopefully we get another query and
we continue to refine our guests until
after we do this for capital T steps
we're done you know we have to actually
find out that we've managed to come up
with a good approximation at least with
respect to all the queries in queue and
this is sort of what the output will be
once we have this we might as well just
give it out to the world all right for
people who sort of like pseudocode
better than funny pictures basically you
know the algorithm takes the database it
starts with some guests and then it runs
this loop where in every round it finds
kind of the worst query might as well
find the worst and doesn't update with
it all right so you know what progress
have we made so far I haven't done
anything for privacy but the progress is
made is that we sort of decomposed the
problem into smaller problems
fortunately differential privacy compose
as well so if we can solve each of the
small problems with differential privacy
we can solve the big problem and we've
also done something else which I think
you'll see later is kind of nice which
is that we sort of separated privacy so
the only part where we touch the data
was finding these queries to do updates
with and we separated that out from how
we do the updates so from a privacy
perspective we don't care how we do the
updates all right so you can plug in any
out any update algorithm for free at
least in as much as you can you know
make this framework okay but I haven't
really told you anything yet that makes
this like a non-trivial approach to
solving the problem maybe you know
this process works but it doesn't finish
until you've asked all the queries all
right so you you get the answer all the
queries you haven't really solved
anything so you know we need one one
more thing to hope for is that we've
hopefully decompose the problem into a
smaller number of subproblems than there
are queries and you know maybe I'll
priori there's no obvious reason why you
should be able to do this you know maybe
each query just conveys new information
but it turns out that using kind of the
theory of online learning in particular
no regret algorithms and the
multiplicative weights update rule it
turns out that we're actually going to
be able to use a small number of queries
in order to approximate the database
well so I'm kind of guessing many people
have seen kind of no regret learning and
multiplicative weights but let me go
through it and if I go through it too
fast feel free to slow me up so the
model so lets you know back up from
private query release for a second the
model is every you know I have some set
of experts maybe these are financial
advisors and you know I want to
distribute my my dollar of investment
every day between the financial advisors
and I want to make sure that I don't you
know pick the worst ones so every day I
split my dollar into some distribution
over the experts I give you know 25
cents to each expert to invest and then
I find out how much money they lost all
right so you can tell how much I think
of financial advisors they're always
going to lose an amount of money between
0 & 1 and so you get this vector and you
know my loss is just the inner product
between d1 my distribution and the loss
vector alright and you know so now
presumably I want to kind of shift some
of my investment to the experts who are
doing well right and one good way to do
this is to use the multiplicative
weights update rule do a little stone in
warmuth although it's been sort of
rediscovered in too many contexts to
count and don't worry so much about what
it is the point is basically it's just a
way of [ __ ]
staying towards the experts who lost the
least money or towards the experts who
away from the experts who lost the most
so now you know i have a new way of
investing my dollar and we get some
losses on day two and that's how much
money I lost and I'll just say you know
the losses on day two can be chosen kind
of after seeing what's happened on day
one all right sort of an important
property although i'm not going to say
too much about it during the talk all
right we go through this forty days and
you know what do i want to guarantee
kind of at the end of t days like it's a
natural thing that I you know might want
to say I can tell you're like the only
person who's going to answer my
questions right beautiful so right I'm
gonna look you know really silly if at
the end of you know at the end of the
year I could have just you know put my
money with one person and that guy did
really well but I put my money with you
know a bunch of clowns so what I want is
a guarantee like this and in fact you
know the multiplicative weights update
will give me this guarantee so first
ignore distribution for a second what it
basically says is no matter what the
losses are if I look in hindsight and I
pick any single expert the amount of
money I lost that's kind of the sum of d
TL t minus the amount of money that
expert lost which is the sum of d LT is
going to be bounded and what's a good
bound the most that expert could have
lost was t so I'm going to get a bat and
I'm going to get a bound of root T so
I'll have lost something that's kind of
sub linear in the number of days and you
know in exchange for this I'll pay this
factor that's logarithmic and the number
of experts all right so this is kind of
the magic of multiplicative weights is
it only get this logarithmic dependence
on the number of experts I should say
there's a constant in there but sort of
allergic to having extra constants and
talks so
alright so guarantee clear it's a very
useful property for things way beyond
differential privacy so people haven't
seen this this is like a really cool
thing to know yeah so this is this is
like tight in general um okay so so yeah
this is the sort of optimal algorithm
for this level of generality alright so
it takes a little work to see what this
has to do with answering counting
queries but let me transform the problem
a little bit so the way I defined it i
have this database that's a collection
of n rows and i asked the question
that's what fraction of those rows
satisfy some property of interest i
could also view my database as a
distribution on the set of possible rose
all right so database in a distribution
are sort of the same thing and so now
i'm going to write my database is this
huge vector saying what fraction of
peoples are of each type and in this
representation the query can be written
just as a vector that says which types
of people satisfy the property and so
sometimes people call these linear
queries because of this representation
that I can write Q of d is just the dot
product between D and Q all right so
this is just like a transformation of
the problem into this really high
dimensional space where the queries are
now linear so once you have that you can
actually do just like a pretty kind of
syntactic translation so I'm going to
think of this no regret learning
algorithm now as an algorithm that's
trying to learn the database all right
so instead of thinking of my set of
experts is just experts I'm going to
think of them as possible rose on the
database this algorithm is keeping track
of the distribution over those possible
rows so it's really keeping track of a
database in this high dimensional
representation and now what it's doing
is it's basically continually adjusting
the database in response to the losses
it sees and
think of the losses as the truth table
of the query so for every expert ex
every expert little X the corresponding
loss is going to be well you know one if
that person satisfies the property all
right and now just you know purely
syntactically this is the guarantee i
get yeah i did rick roll you at several
points thank you for catching that not
enough people ask questions explicitly
about whether they were rickrolled
during my talk um a minute to get back
into so um okay so purely syntactically
this is what the no regret guarantee
becomes all right so the set of expert
says size 2 to the D so that becomes
deep and let's look at what this says
all right I'm maintaining kind of an
iterative Lee changing approximation to
the database d 1 through D capital T and
well this is the regret I have it's the
amount you know it's the sum over all
the days T of the amount by which my
current approximation overestimated the
answer to the query all right so we have
a bound over all T steps of the total
amount by which i overestimated the
answer to the query and it's a bound
that's kind of growing sub linearly and
t
alright so this kind of you know suggest
the following thing to do you know I put
in purple the places where we had to
make kind of a design choice so let's
use multiplicative weights as that
design choice let's start with the
uniform distribution and let's find the
worst query and every day we're going to
do the multiplicative way it's update
with that query all right so this is
still an on private algorithm but I
claim this is going to have some good
properties that are going to make it
easy to make private all right so
remember I said that you know the goal
would be for this algorithm to kind of
converge to the real database fairly
quickly all right that's that's what I
said we kind of need for privacy and
let's look at sort of why that might be
true so this is the regret bound I have
I said that for every kind of sequence
of queries you choose which correspond
to losses the sum of the amount by which
I overestimate the answers to the
queries is going to be bounded so let's
suppose that every day I managed to find
some query for which my current guess
overestimates the answer by alpha all
right then I can take my regret bounds
and on the right I can say that well the
total amount I overestimate is at least
alpha times T all right so now just
rearranging what they see is that kind
of the longest sequence of queries I
find that can satisfy this property is
going to have length about D over alpha
squared since that's the longest
sequence I can find you know if I
managed to actually do this 40 steps at
the end of those T steps I actually must
have it be that there's no query in fact
you know not just in my query set just
there's no query for which I
overestimate the answer by more than
alpha right
and now this is a good point to say I've
been kind of cheating a little bit so I
keep talking about overestimating the
answers to queries this is just a
simplification but it's okay because I'm
just going to assume the set of query is
this kind of closed under negation so
you know if there's a query which I
underestimate there'll be some query for
which I overestimate so this is really
the statement I want write this
statement is exactly the definition of
saying that DT is kind of an alpha
accurate answer to the family of queries
q picked a good time to pause alright so
let's go back to the picture of what the
algorithm is and now I get to say
exactly how many rounds I need to run
this algorithm for all right so I only
need to run this algorithm for about D
over alpha squared rounds yeah
absolutely emphasize that not only you
said was there no query and cute for
which you would have a difference see
right there is no fairy at all right i
mean if i can actually you know do this
and if i really find like a maximal
sequence of queries that satisfy this
property than yeah obviously i won't be
able to answer you know every possible
query and still get privacy but in
principle if I made QB like all the
queries I could eventually run this
algorithm and just you know get flirting
the you know the whole database exactly
in the non private setting okay
alright so back to the blueprint you
know we've up to privacy sort of the
whole algorithm right so there's just an
algorithm for learning the database and
you know so far it doesn't do anything
for privacy but I claim it's a good one
to make private so just again the
algorithm is you know you start with the
uniform distribution viewing the
database in this big high dimensional
representation you run for about D over
alpha squared rounds every round you
choose kind of the worst query and then
you run a multiplicative weights update
at the end of the day you output you
know the last database and notice that
you know I mean this is a fairly small
number of rounds to run for it the
number the set of queries I think
typically you should think of as much
larger than this quantity right so for
instance if if alpha is a constant this
is like saying you can only ask like a
constant number of queries about each
attribute and so you know typically this
is going to be a small number of rounds
compared to the trivial solution where
you just ask all the queries and you
know what do we have to do to make this
a private algorithm right so we only
touch the database in in one place all
right I put it in red to indicate this
is where we touch the database so it's
the only thing we actually have to worry
about possibly not satisfying
differential privacy ah yes so we have
to make it differentially private and I
claim there's a really good way to do
that so it's something that Katrina went
over in her talk yesterday let me just
give you kind of the skeleton of what
the tool is it's a really useful tool to
know for differential privacy all right
so it's called the exponential mechanism
to do two McSherry and tall waar from
2007 and what it does basically I mean
what's the problem I have I want to
choose from kind of a discrete set and I
want to choose an element from the
discrete set that maximizes some
quantity that depends on the data but it
depends on the data and only sort of a
mild way so changing one row of the
database can't change this difference by
too much right and so the idea is that I
can't just choose the maximum that could
depend on the data I can't just choose
the art max but what i can do is i can
sample a query in a way
that puts most of the mass on queries
that make this quantity large and
there's a particular form for how you
want to do that you choose some privacy
parameter epsilon zero and you sort of
exponentially weight towards queries
with large answers all right so how you
actually set you know this up is sort of
not what I want to talk about the point
is that there is a way of making a
distribution that's differentially
private and shifts a lot of mass towards
good queries and here's the kind of
guarantee it gives you so kind of ignore
this first part what it's going to do is
it's going to output some query q sub T
whose score right so for which this
quantity is at least the max minus some
error you know alpha over 2 all right
that's the type of guarantee it gives me
it gives me something whose score is
close to the best score and in order to
do this I need enough data to make this
distribution kind of concentrated on
good queries and it turns out the amount
of data I need is about logarithmic in
the number of queries and in verse in
the Alpha the you know the accuracy
parameter alpha and the privacy
parameter and so the key here is this
logarithmic dependence on the number of
queries that's what makes the
exponential mechanism really powerful
you get to choose from a huge set but
you need data that depends only
logarithmic Leon the size of the set if
you just naively kind of you know
estimated all these quantities by adding
noise you need something that depends
polynomial e on the number of queries
all right so this is the tool I'm going
to use in the multiplicative weights
algorithm all right so now in order to
get a private implementation instead of
choosing the arc max I'm going to sample
queries in this way I want to just call
it like a quick connection to another
quick connection to learning so if you
look at what I'm doing here I'm actually
solving an agnostic learning problem so
I am trying to find a hyperplane q that
sort of best classifies a data elements
as being either from this fake
distribution DT or the real one D and
I'm trying to do it privately so really
kind of
any private agnostic learning algorithm
will do here that's sort of a useful
perspective to keep in mind for variance
this is just a generic private agnostic
learner from the paper by casillas wanna
Sun at all from 2007 that's all it is
all right so this is almost the entire
algorithm except for one more thing
which is what privacy parameter do I use
here I left it at just some sort of
abstract epsilon zero yes yeah so sorry
it's a little bit you know so I mean you
can make it formal but the way I said it
was little half-baked the idea is that
basically this quantity this inner
product of dt minus D and Q is basically
sort of how well cue the vector kind of
separates points as being either from dt
or being from d all right so these are
both kind of collections of points and I
want this will be large if kind of you
know more of the points in dt fall on
one side of Q then the points in d so
that's exactly like you know an agnostic
learning problem it's finding the
hyperplane that best classifies your
points that make any more sense than the
first thing I said oh so there is no
perfect separator right so it's not the
case that like every point in dt
satisfies the query and every point in D
doesn't it's just you know points in dt
or slightly more likely to satisfy the
query ok so the algorithm and as I said
you know the only condition I need
basically is that as long as there's
some query with error let's say alpha I
need to find a query with error let's
say alpha over 2 right i mean that's the
condition i need to make sure that i
find a query that's sort of good enough
to make progress as long as one exists
and i told you that basically in order
to guarantee that I do that I need to
may I need enough data that this
algorithm works well and a ton of data
is this quantity and how many times do I
need to run it only need to run it t
times so lets you know just remind
ourselves what the composition theorem
says this is the kind of strengthened
composition theorem due to dwarf
women vuitton and what it basically says
is that if I'm shooting for epsilon
delta differential privacy and I want to
get it by running T separate algorithms
possibly you know adaptively chosen then
I need to run each one of those
algorithms with some parameter epsilon
zero that's approximately epsilon over
the square root of T and there's some
fudge factor Delta in here that will pop
up here but basically think of it as I
want epsilon differential privacy so i
need to use epsilon over root t
differential privacy at each step all
right we have a nice bound on T you can
just plug it all in and this is the
algorithm and notice there's only one
place where I needed to assume I had a
lot of data is to make this step work
here's how much data i need so I'll
unpack this on kind of the next slide
all right the summary so this is what we
get so we have this algorithm it takes
in a database and a set of counting
queries you give it it satisfies epsilon
delta differential privacy and it's
going to at the end of the day out put
some database d sub T such that if you
evaluate any of the queries you asked on
that database you'll get a very similar
answer to what you would have gotten on
the real database and the amount of data
you need it's only growing logarithmic
Lee in the number of queries it has this
kind of dependence on the number of
attributes in the database and it has an
inverse polynomial dependence on the
accuracy parameter alpha and this kind
of linear inverse dependence on epsilon
some Delta and some failure
probabilities that I'm hiding all right
any question at the algorithm what the
guarantee means
right Tina you just want to sort of like
find a fixed set of queries yeah I just
hand you some big bucket some digging
around queries all right so a couple
things this one so finding a database
with small l1 distance from the true
database sort of is a privacy violation
I mean that would be but the question is
can you find a database that sort of you
know looks like the real one with
respect to these queries and the answer
your question is sort of yes so if you
take say this big set of queries q and
you just choose a random set of about
end of them and now you you just find a
database that answers those queries well
then you know generalization will apply
it will actually do well on average for
the queries in queue I don't have like a
completely convincing answer off the top
of my head I would guess somehow at
least in this framework if you want to
answer every query in queue you kind of
need the ability to you no answer some
accurately see which ones you failed on
and and you know it was also praising
for every database implies the answer is
at least in general ginger in some
specific cases there are okay hey that's
your question
alright well thank you um all right so
this is what you get out of
multiplicative weights this is one
algorithm in a huge space of algorithms
you could have used to solve this
problem so I want to talk a little bit
about why this is a good one and I think
you know one of the reasons to say this
is a good one is because it's sort of
nearly optimal at this level of
generality and so you know this is going
to talk about lower bounds but since
according to Katrina I'm like the Grinch
who stole differential privacy i'm sort
of obligated to give you a lower bound
in every talk you're gonna get to so in
recent joint work with Mark Bunn and
salil vuitton what we showed is that
basically for this kind of guarantee
multiplicative weights is optimal so if
you want an algorithm that takes in a
large set of queries in arbitrary large
set of queries it needs to have this
much data to work with if it's going to
satisfy accuracy and privacy all right
so I don't want to overstate this this
is for some set of queries yeah in train
which was good okay so notice I mean I
needed to be able to kind of to make
this algorithm work I needed to be able
to express my query as kind of an inner
product between some representation of
the database there if you have you know
queries that aren't counting queries
that aren't sort of like linear in the
set of rows you can always do this by
kind of blowing up until I can even hire
dementia and you'll get a kind of
similar type of guarantee um I'm not
sure if you get bounds quite this strong
but basically this works for kind of any
query whose sensitivity to changing one
row of the database is 1 and n right
that's sort of for privacy that's the
only property of counting queries I used
for this particular algorithm I used a
little bit of additional structure
yeah so so you know think of alphas like
one in a thousand or like 1n root N or
something it sits between zero and one
yeah yeah there's like a logarithmic
dependence on delta square well in this
in my preferred language it's just a log
but yeah there's some some dependence on
those yeah slog one over Delta so it
comes from so notice see I said you need
to run it with privacy parameter kind of
epsilon over routine really you kind of
need to run it with privacy parameter
like epsilon over root t log 1 over
Delta I mean yeah so the composition is
basically a concentration of measure
statement so it kind of says that you
know the expected privacy loss kind of
grows is the square root of T there's
some probability that it will like
massively exceed its expectation and the
log 1 over Delta kind of bounty no
controls that probability they did it
because there's you know just too many
parameters and some of these problems
had to pick one to go you did with
epsilon zero you would get like a D here
and then alpha cubed you actually still
get an epsilon um but yeah I mean when
you you get something worse but that's a
good point so you know everything i'm
saying is going to have sort of an
epsilon zero analog if that you know
something important
ah that's right good point okay
everything I put in the slides okay so
all right so this is one lower valence
says you know this is sort of the right
algorithm for answering an arbitrary set
of queries of what you care about is how
much data you need but you know I get
something like very wasteful in
designing algorithm i took this nice
compact database and I blew it up into
this huge you know to to the D
dimensional vector so you might think
that that's you know i mean it is
imposing a big cost so basically you
know what is the running time of the
algorithm in most reasonable settings
it's going to be dominated by the need
to do this multiplicative weights update
step on like two to the d experts and of
course it's got some other factors in it
so like you know you also have to just
be able to evaluate the query non
privately that might itself be already
inefficient but typically won't be so
the real you know the dominant factor in
the running time is 2 to the d
exponential in the dimensionality the
data and you know even though it seemed
like a very wasteful step in the
algorithm that's also actually inherent
for kind of an algorithm at this level
of generality so if i want some
differentially private algorithm that i
can give it sort of an arbitrary set of
queries it kind of runs in sort of
genuinely polynomial time in its input
length then it needs a lot more data it
needs like square root of the number of
queries records on the database which is
what i would have needed for this kind
of trivial approach of just adding noise
independently all right this you know
for people who these things this is sort
of under the assumption that we have
secure crypto which is a fairly
believable assumption i hope all right
so i don't want to overstate this either
actually Katrina and Frank and Moritz
have sort of an implementation of this
algorithm where they show it can be
practical in some cases when wendy is
not too big there was a talk by
adjusting yesterday about kind of a
variant of this algorithm that can be
even more practical in some settings but
at least in theory this seemingly very
wasteful step is actually kind of
inherent for any approach to solving the
problem alright so this algorithm
basically gives kind of the optimal
amount of you know the optimal data
requirement and the optimal running time
for this problem so it's a very strong
problem
you know this is sort of in some sense
the right solution to it all right so
that's sort of all I have to say about
what I call offline multiplicative
weights this is kind of the thing I'm
going to go into and like the most depth
for the rest of the talk I want to talk
you know I want to give a few variants
so first I want to talk about a variant
to the online setting where you don't
actually have the set of queries up
front then I want to talk about just you
know variants two special cases of the
problem and then I want to spend a
little time zooming in on kind of a
particular special case of the problem
where the queries have a very nice
structure which has been an open and
it's been sort of an open problem in the
literature and I want to talk about how
different learning theoretic techniques
sort of in conjunction with
multiplicative weights give interesting
solutions all right so you know what's
the online problem it's exactly the same
except instead of getting a big set of
queries and producing some summary I
just get an online sequence of queries
and I just give out an answer to each
one so and this is a good point to
reflect notice that the algorithm we
designed that I just talked about was
based on online learning techniques but
it was solving an offline problem the
online learning was just useful for
getting a nice algorithm that we can
make private but of course you know it
also kind of naturally leads to an
online algorithm for the problem and so
you know what's the challenge about
adapting this to the online setting well
you know one step in the algorithm was
to kind of have all my queries and I
just sort of ask you know is my database
good for all these queries and I get
back one of the queries for which it's
not good in the online setting I can't
do that I mean I get this query I have
to answer it so kind of all I can do is
I can ask is my current approximation
good for that query I mean the sort of
you know the only like obvious thing to
do and maybe I find out that it is
because it's you know like it's not a
very good approximation to the database
in general but for like one query it
might be fine so maybe what I'll do is I
don't want to give out anything
dependent on the real day-to-day so I'll
just
give out the answer on my approximation
intuitively that's kind of a good way of
like not revealing too much about the
real database but it doesn't solve the
problem because just this information
that you know this is a good
approximation reveal something about the
database alright so the blueprint just
kind of proceeds this way you know now I
get some other query and I ask well is
my current database good for that query
and maybe this time it's not right I get
some I find out it's not it's answer
needs to be different so maybe in this
case I'll bite the bullet and I'll give
out a noisy version of the answer on the
true database right we're just you know
ignoring privacy for a second I'll give
out the answer on the true database and
we'll just sort of remember we have to
worry about privacy here but you know at
least someone was nice enough to ask a
query that gives me some information
about the database will run the update
algorithm and I'll try to refine my
approximation and I'll just kind of
proceed this way right so instead of
sort of only finding queries that induce
updates I'll go through this whole
process and at every step will classify
the query into either one we already do
well on or one that we need to do an
update on okay and from a privacy
standpoint the hope is that maybe these
queries where I just say you know what
the current approximation is all right
don't actually cost me much from a
privacy standpoint maybe I only need to
pay for these updates and you know the
advantage is that there won't be that
many updates so the same argument for
why we only needed a few steps in the
offline case will also apply to the
online case to say that there can only
be a small number of updates even though
there are lots of queries all right so
this is kind of a pseudocode for the
online framework you know I just get the
sequence of queries every round I check
is my current approximation good if it's
good I answer with this kind of a you
know default answer if it's bad I'm
going to answer with the you know the
using the real database but I'm going to
do an update and I claim that I won't do
that many updates but i still haven't
you know explain why this is private
so in this case this only happens a
small number of times so i can solve it
by just adding noise to the answer hey
you know I don't want to go into exactly
how much noise but the point is that
this only happens a small number of
times I just add noise and it's a good
approach this sort of thing can happen a
lot of times and we need something to
argue for why it doesn't hurt us and
arguing for why it doesn't hurt us too
much is you know a little too technical
for the talk or just too many things but
I want to just explain like a very nice
primitive that I think you know for
everyone who actually designs
differentially private algorithms is
really useful in theory and in practice
and I think it's good to know and you
know this is one application of it so
here's the primitive I think it's called
the threshold algorithm or sometimes the
sparse vector technique and here's what
it does so suppose we have a stream of
queries they're arriving online and
somehow someone has just promised us
that there's only a single query whose
answer is large larger than maybe alpha
over 2 all right forget why that might
be true but you know maybe I just know
there's not a lot of queries whose
answer is large then I claim there's an
epsilon zero differentially private
algorithm that with high probability
will give me an accurate answer to every
single one of these k queries as long as
the amount of data i have is grew is you
know about logarithmic in the total
number of queries all right so if i just
answer each one of these queries with
noise i would replace this log k with a
root k but because i know that most of
the queries have kind of dull answers i
can improve it to logarithmic in the
number of queries all right this is just
a really useful primitive and it takes
you know a few steps to see how it
applies here but intuitively the queries
are going to be how different is my
approximation from the true answer to
the query you ask me all right and you
know if I sort of break this whole
algorithm up into these kind of blocks
where I think about you know all the
queries before the first update all the
queries before the second update and so
on you know each one of the
these is going to be some stream of
queries where only the last one had a
large answer and so I only need an
amount of data that's kind of
logarithmic in the length of the stream
which you know at most is the length of
the whole stream so that's where i'm
going to get my kind of logarithmic
dependence in the number in the total
number of queries even though in
principle I'm giving up a little bit of
information you know at every round all
right so it's just you know a high-level
overview of what's like the main idea
and going from the offline algorithm to
the online algorithm I probably went by
a little fast but I think this is like a
really useful thing to be aware of is
that if you can sort of guess the answer
to most of the queries you only pay for
the number of times your guesses are
wrong all right and you know if you
actually work this up formally you get
basically the same guarantee that we got
in the offline setting so we had this
optimal algorithm for the offline
setting and it turns out you give up
almost nothing to work in the online
setting so the running time guarantee
changes a little bit in that now you
know you talk about how much time it
took per query it's in the worst case i
did an update it was two to the D but
everything's basically the same alright
so that was offline and online
multiplicative weights let me just
really quickly kind of summarize some
like variants of multiplicative weights
that have also been used in the
literature to solve special cases of
this query release problem so you know
the lower bounds tell you something
about answering arbitrary queries what
about kind of interesting special cases
and you know the big point here is that
by having this blueprint for an
algorithm that separates privacy from
this online learning component I can
just like swapping a good no regret
algorithm a good online learning
algorithm and solve you know new
problems potentially using some
additional structure of that problem so
the first place that we did that is in
joint work with on a palm and Aaron
where we were interested in answering
queries on graphs so basically a special
case of counting queries where each row
of the database is like an edge and I
want to know what fraction of these
edges cross between some sed s and some
settee the the results
selves are you no not particularly I
don't want to go into I just want to say
that in some settings you can actually
reduce the amount of data you need for
this problem over what you get by
applying multiplicative weights using a
different algorithm based on the cuts
decomposition of fries and con on I
think is really just like gradient
descent with the I like to go up the cut
decomposition because it sounds specific
to the problem which is also you know
why we thought to use it all right so
kind of an even nicer example of this is
something done by jane and the kurta
where they replace multiplicative
weights with algorithm from the mirror
descent families like a very general
family of online learners that includes
multiplicative weights they also had
some applications to cut queries the
main idea here is that when you know
something about kind of the norm of the
database and the norm of the set of
queries you get to get a regret bound in
terms of those quantities so
multiplicative weights we kind of view
the database as a distribution it has
small l1 norm the query has small L
infinity norm and you can consider other
norm pairs and that gives you
interesting things in certain special
cases also worked by a blooming Roth I'm
kind of sparse queries so there they
were more focused on the running time so
you want to run kind of an implicit
version of multiplicative waits in the
case where each query only accepts like
a small number of things Aaron doesn't
even seem to like have heard of this
result which is amazing looking really
skeptical oh great no I'm really glad
you asked this is a my google for sparse
like I tried googling a bunch of things
involving sparse and I eventually got
this picture of a very sparsely
populated Yankee Stadium during batting
practice that's apparently if you google
for like sparse population oh no
actually this bezel aching Google mirror
descent is like the most literal thing
you would ever think of from mirror
descent it's like a plane landing and
its wing is mirrored this some guy tried
to sell this for like five thousand
dollars
uh you go to Google Images and you take
a screenshot oh yeah no no I was just
kidding obviously area yeah yeah various
okay so that's plenty to save stars
queries ice also in our result that by
huang and Roth they considered kind of
distance queries it's another counting
query where it's sort of in a continuous
domain but the idea is that you know
everyone is a point in some space I give
you a query which is some other point in
that space and you want to know the
average distance from people to that
point and they showed how to get an
efficient algorithm using kind of a
specialized no regret algorithm for the
problem and it also fits in this frame
works all these things just kind of come
you know you can only think about online
learning you don't to think about
privacy you can get all these things all
right so the last thing I want to talk
about is I want to zoom in on kind of a
particular special case of counting for
your release that's gotten a lot of
attention and I want to talk about how
you know we're starting to make progress
on that using a technique of polynomial
approximations which is really prevalent
in kind of pack agnostic learning and i
want to say why it is useful for the
problem all right so this was the
generic private counting query release
problem i had sort of an arbitrary
property that i wanted the rose to
satisfy and i'm just going to assume
that the property i want is a that the
rose satisfies some monotone KO a
disjunction so just the or of some
number of bits and the number of bits
will be at most k k is a new parameter
since I introduced a new parameter I'm
going to take one away and we're just
going to fix alpha to be one and a
hundred for the rest of the talk and of
course the sanitizer doesn't really take
any input anymore I mean it just knows
it wants to solve this junctions it's
useful facts for small enough you know
for a fairly small choice of K like
constant or slow
growing in D the number of queries is
not so huge it's about D to the K and
also you know this monotone disjunction
is not really important it could be a
conjunction non monotone sometimes you
will call these marginal queries because
I'm kind of asking for the marginal
distribution on a small number of
attributes it's also sometimes called
the contingency table which is really
widely used in like official statistics
so this is a well motivated problem it's
an important one to solve for
differential privacy let me you know
just give you a sense of what happens if
i apply generic techniques to the
problem so as I said you should always
think about what happens if I just write
down the answer to all the conjunctions
and I add noise often called the Laplace
mechanism so the amount of data i need
square root of the number of queries
it's about D to the K over to the
running time I need is sort of is
proportional to the number of queries
that's like D to the K on the other end
of the spectrum I could apply private
multiplicative weight so I pay this to
to the D running time which now seems
fairly prohibitive because you know it's
much larger than the number of queries
usually and the amount of data I need if
you just you know translate the bound
it's going to be about k the number of
attributes times root of the dimension
and that's that's optimal for the
problem and kind of the lower bounds
sort of say that there's like a
threshold here so anything kind of below
here has to use some special structure
of disjunctions and there's maybe a bit
strong but you know I'll call it the
holy grail of answering koa destruction
queries if you can get something that
works with a database of size about K
root B and runs in a polynomial time in
candy all right and as I said you know
like the bottleneck in this private
multiplicative waits algorithm is sort
of taking this database and kind of
blowing it up to this huge distribution
and you know even though we know it's
kind of maybe not it's specifically
necessary but this kind of running time
is necessary maybe we can do something
more clever when we only care about a
specific set of queries and the idea is
sort of just the following like switch
in perspective so normally you think of
the queries as a function you apply to
the database
I want to think of the database is sort
of a function i apply to queries so i
want to think of the database of
specifying some function f that takes
the query and gives the answer and you
know so far as a sort of pointless but
the reason to do it is that sometimes
when q is a small set of queries or a
nice set of queries this will be a
function with particular structure so
it'll be some nice thing you know maybe
it'll will itself be like a half space
or a disjunction there's something nice
and you know we can get more efficient
algorithms potentially by exploiting the
structure and you know that's kind of
what learning theory does write it so a
lot of what learning theory is is you
know nice structural properties of
simple functions like this all right so
once you have this view you can actually
turn this into a general theory so I
only want to state an approximate
theorem but heart rockland answer video
sort of basically showed something that
has the flavor of saying if this
function is learnable so if I can sort
of you know I don't know d I know I have
some function from this family if I can
learn it in a particular sense then I
get a query release algorithm for the
family q all right so sort of an
approximate theorem they do sort of a
lot of steps and transformations and a
lot of parameters but this basically
gives us confidence that funk when this
function is learnable we should be able
to get an efficient algorithm this I
should say was sort of implicit in some
earlier works on disjunctions and you
know they made it a nice general theory
but what I'm going to kind of finish up
talking about is not the general
reduction but how to use sort of the
techniques to get ya oh chirag chic
live-ins kothari and lee the paper on
has some title that doesn't include
privacy it's like the noise sensitivity
of sub modular functions and it includes
like a sweet result about privately
releasing disjunctions is like a
corollary somewhere
yeah so I mean I'm really sort of
deliberately because I don't really want
to talk about any algorithms you get out
of this theorem I just want to sort of
say that you know like it's not sort of
it's not just an intuition there is sort
of a way of formalizing a connection all
right but so I'm going to talk about
sort of what some of the specific
techniques are I'm roughly going to sort
of give something based on some joint
work I did with Justin thayler and so
little bit on and a follow up with
Karthik Chandra Shekar and Justin
thayler and Andrew Juan all right so
just using this reduction that they gave
you basically get this result you get
that you know you get roughly the same
running times the Laplace mechanism at
least polynomial but you can improve the
database size somewhat significantly
when K is large all right so using this
kind of connection to learning I'll
obviously say you know how the
algorithms work you can improve the data
requirement we showed kind of a
follow-up paper that you can also
improve the running time you can
actually run in time sub linear in the
number of queries which is often hard to
achieve and then you know what we
considered in this follow-up work is
what if I sort of take this database
size is the hard constraint so I really
don't have that much data i just want to
do as much as i can for running time and
we gave some algorithm that runs in
times a tattoo to the little o of the
number of attributes slightly all right
so let me just sort of talk about the
techniques that go into these results I
will say there are other results some of
which use learning theory techniques but
give kind of average error variance
these are sort of nice but I like to
mostly focus on this worst-case error so
I want accuracy for all queries I also
want to call attention to another result
by Cynthia kunal and saw show that maybe
one of them is going to talk about I
don't know where they sort of consider
the opposite parameter regime we're
running time is the hard constraint and
you want to get kind of an improvement
and data and they get sort of an optimal
algorithm for K is too and this is using
some sort of very different type of
techniques but it's worth keeping in
mind rom session all right there'll be a
rumpus about this
alright so finally after sort of setting
up the problem I can sort of explain
what the kind of main idea is and you
know what did I say I said we want to
view this as a map that takes the
description of a disjunction and outputs
an answer and I said that you know
because disjunctions are simple queries
this might have a simple structure and
what do I mean by simple structure and
hopefully what I mean is that i can
write for any database i can write this
function f d as a linear combination of
some small number of like basis
functions alright and in particular i
can write it as a linear combination
where the sum of the coefficients is
small so it's what i mean by low weight
and this is sort of like a the main kind
of thing that underlies the most
efficient distribution for you packing
agnostic learning algorithms and i'll
show you know why it's a useful concept
also going to formalize what it means
let's go back to the multiplicative
weights and see what it's doing so I had
a distribution over experts where there
was one expert for every person that
could be in the database and the sort of
the losses that I gave that expert were
just whatever that expert would have
said so you know if I had a database
that just consisted of that one person
how would that person have answered the
query and I want to think about this a
little bit differently using this sort
of shift in perspective that I described
so what I want to think of the experts
as functions so there's a function for
each record in the database and the
database is just kind of a linear
combination of those functions and
because it's a distribution its weight
as one so the l1 norm of its
coefficients the sum of the absolute
values is just one and so I haven't
actually changed what multiplicative
weights is doing I'm just reinterpreting
it we're the experts are these functions
F sub X and the loss corresponding to
each query for you know the loss for
each expert for each query is whatever
that expert would have said in response
to that query
alright so they're just sort of syntax
at this point alright so I just want to
think of multiplicative weights as sort
of treating the databases like a weight
one linear combination of some set of
functions and I'm going to think of the
set of functions as the basis and you
know what happens if I change the weight
all right so does the weight really all
that important in multiplicative weights
I mean I claim that it's not so if I
just instead of distributing one dollar
every day i distribute w dollars I just
you know my loss of scaled by W and
nothing happened so my regret bound
scales with the weight hey so this is
sort of the important property I used
for multiplicative weights was that the
god I just use weight twice in the same
sentence to mean different things for
the update algorithm the weight of the
coefficients was one but i can use sort
of any weight that i want all right so
you know i claim that sort of the
private multiplicative weights algorithm
is just a particular instantiation of
this framework where everything's we'll
wait one linear combination of a huge
set of functions and the huge set of
functions is the bottleneck in the
running time but this weight one is why
you get kind of optimal data complexity
so all they improved algorithms for
disjunction queries that I'm going to
talk about are just going to be sort of
changing this basis so instead of having
one basis function for each possible
person in the database I'm just going to
have some set of basis functions and I
want to claim that I can treat the
database as well I kind of a low weight
combination of those basis functions all
right so let me just sort of give a
definition of what i mean about that I
don't want to parse it completely but
remember I said I'm viewing this
database as this map so let's have a set
of a set of maps this is my basis f and
I'm going to claim that it's sort of a
good approximate basis for my set of
queries if for every database there's a
wait one awake w linear combination of
functions that kind of uniformly
approximates the database with respect
to all the queries and I'll just you
know fix this desired degree of
approximation
it's going to get rolled into sort of
the final out error of the algorithm all
right let's clear enough and I just have
a set of functions and I view my
database of some kind of linear
combination of those functions where the
linear combination has bounded
coefficients all right so how does this
affect the final guarantee m and it gets
so let me just assume i can construct
one of these low weight basis this was
the guarantee we had before and what we
show although i should say it's a fairly
sort of you know mostly just follows
from sort of techniques and learning
theory that if instead you replace your
basis with something of weight w you're
going to blow up the amount of data you
need by w and you're right but you're
running time is going to just be
proportional to the number of basis
functions
we talked a little bit confused about
how you go mapping the functions back to
a database queries right so okay good so
so that's sort of um okay explain so
what I'm not going to do is I'm not
going to output a bona fide database so
in the private multiplicative weights
algorithm before what I output was like
a distribution over sort of possible
people in the database which I could
just view as a database itself here what
I'm going to give you is like a
distribution over these functions and
sort of the key idea is that you know
the set of functions i'm using a sort of
their only even defined on these
disjunction queries they don't even make
sense it doesn't necessarily even make
sense to talk about what they mean for
other queries right so there may be some
way of like taking the answers to all
these disjunctions and kind of you know
associating in fact there is i can
always associate it with some database
that would give approximately those
answers but the key idea for something
for efficiency is that I'm avoiding this
bottleneck that's inherent for answering
arbitrary queries by coming up with the
representation that sort of only even
makes sense for answering the small set
of queries and they probably should have
said that earlier thanks for asking that
question
yeah I guess specifically for
disjunctions conjunctions and we know it
can be hard to give in just approximate
answers the queries to generate a yes
yes yes we do so I'm only allowed to
talk about to lower mountains in the
stocks so what Adams alluding to is that
you know not only does this sort of seem
to avoid the bottleneck of
multiplicative weights there's actually
a lower bound this of any algorithm that
privately generates an actual database
that preserves the answers to the those
conjunction queries also has to have
running time that's exponential in the
dimension so this is sort of nest using
this kind of changing the representation
is sort of inherent for this type of
guarantee yes just go back to the
definition of the basis for moving yeah
I got wrong so these episode acquit
could be oh sorry so that is not really
important yeah I think you can actually
think it's sort of without loss of
generality but yeah so and there's
nothing special about being billion all
right so this just says you have a low
weight basis you get a different version
of multiplicative weights that's going
to have a different set of parameter
trade-offs hopefully I get you know
better running time and hopefully I
don't blow up the weight too much
alright and where do these low weight
basis come from they come from a very
powerful technique that's used everyone
learning which is approximating
functions by polynomials preferably low
degree polynomials with bounded
coefficients this is sort of the most
usually the most efficient way of you
know pack er agnostic learning most of
your favorite function classes in the
kind of distribution free setting and
it's you know been used for destructions
let me just explain what the technique
is so me just give a head a little bit
so I said I have a map from queries to
answer so how do I represent the query
well for a disjunction let me just
represent
the query by some vector Y which says
you know it's going to have D bits and
it's just going to say which literals I
include in the disjunction all rights so
like for this one the vector y would be
1100 because one them two are in doing
for and on all right and I claim it's
sufficient to just approximate you know
one row databases because the database
itself is a linear combination of rows
if I approximate each one by a linear
combination things work out so but a
claim I want is I want that for every
possible row of the database I have some
function P sub X that has it's a
polynomial of degree capital t wait W
and for every why that corresponds to a
KO a disjunction it's going to be a good
approximation to F sub X and when I say
every why that corresponds to a KO a
disjuncture notice that since this is AK
way destruction it only has k literals
so there's only k nonzero coordinates of
why even though it's a D dimensional
vector this is a slightly non standard
version of sort of a canonical problem
in approximation theory and it turns out
just purely by coincidence that you know
when I view this as a function of Y it's
also a disjunction so basically you take
all the ones that are present in the row
x and you look at whether any of those
are actually asked about in the query
happens to be a disjunction but it may
not be a que way disjunction and they
have all worlds and just buy some sort
of simple transformations it's
sufficient to approximate just the
single d variate or function which is a
well-studied problem as the answer is
known but I I care about you know only
about approximating it on inputs with it
most que non zeros all right so
alright this is just a statement that
says you know if I have such a
polynomial approximation I get a low
weight basis where the basis functions
are all of the monomials of a particular
degree it's what a polynomial is it's a
linear combination of monomials and what
I care about is the sum of the
coefficients in the polynomial and the
degree all right so sort of starting to
run short on time so mmm maybe skip a
little of the detail but let me just say
the key idea for why I can get a
non-trivial approximation to the or
function and it's this picture so let's
just consider a univariate function and
I want it to be 0 when evaluated on 0
and I want it to be one when I evaluate
on anything from one up to K or you know
say K is like 20 so I want a function
that kind of looks like this except i
want you know these things to be like
really close to one so just using
polynomial interpolation I can always
get a polynomial of degree K that does
this but there's a really nice
polynomial called the chebyshev
polynomial that approximately does this
and its degree is only about root of K
then the y-axis is the value of the
function is just a univariate function
all right so you kind of skip over this
and just get to the punch line you know
using just this univariate function I
can derive a polynomial that
approximates the D variate or function
on all the inputs with it most K
non-zeros its degree is going to be some
constant times root K and its weight the
sum of the absolute values of all of its
coefficients is about D to the square
root K alright and plugging that in to
this framework I get exactly this result
it's actually a different algorithm but
you know you get this result you get
that the database size is dominated by
the weight which is about D to the root
K the running time is actually going to
be dominated by the number of queries
because the set of basis functions is
very small but so you know you get a
much better running time than
multiplicative weights you get a much
better database size than the Laplace
mechanism
you get something kind of weird in
between here let me also say me to skip
head so in the low pose you don't want
to tolerate this high weight you want to
get a very low weight then there's a way
of kind of composing two different
approximations that will give you
something with very low weight weight
independent of K just like a fixed
polynomial in D and a very small one at
that and its degree will be non-trivial
so its degree won't be D which is the
largest kind of interesting degree it
will be some uh you know d to something
smaller than one and we also show that
this kind of thing is optimal so this is
like new result from work with Karthik
Justin and Andrew where we showed how to
get this very low weight polynomial that
approximates or with some kind of non
trivial degree sorry for kind of rushing
through this doesn't have that much
specific to do with privacy and it's
kind of all right so we use that to get
you know this point on the trade-off we
get something where we pay just a tiny
bit in the amount of data you need and
you get some improvement in the runtime
so this improvement will be something
like you know d to the one minus a
little bit and the luda too so we're
able to you know this leads to sort of
an inherently interesting question that
is now abstracted totally away from
privacy which is what's the smallest you
know what are the right sort of weight
basis size trade-offs for interesting
functions that come up you know in the
course of designing differentially
private algorithms the question that's
actually been sort of very well studied
for like a hundred years but the
particular requirements of at least this
problem k-way disjunctions seems to lead
to some you know new questions that
haven't been resolved so we were able to
show that basically this you know sort
of very small improvement we get is
actually the best you can do if you use
a polynomial if you want to keep the
weight fixed you can't reduce the degree
any more than we do in the high weight
setting this sort of thing was known
that polynomials are sort of the best
approximation it's the best basis you
can get do the social sure Stav
at least the general theorem maybe a
particular was known earlier i'll just
call attention to that you know if you
don't assume polynomials you just want
to know the smallest very low weight
basis for approximating all the KOA
disjunctions it's a nice open question
that would be useful to resolve and i'm
sure by considering other families of
queries you get lots of questions at
this parent so maybe you can improve
this and I think that sort of I want to
kind of conclude on this thought that I
want to sort of go back to the slide I
put up at the beginning so you know what
I've just been talking about our ways to
get really good private algorithms by
using learning algorithms and it might
seem like a very limiting thing to do
but for general private query release it
gives you sort of the optimal algorithm
in terms of running time and the amount
of data you need and you know as I said
it fits in this very general framework
where you can plug in you know different
algorithms and get different things for
special cases but in those settings like
disjunctions it's not at all clear that
this gives you the best algorithms I
mean it gives you improvements but it's
not clear why this should give you the
best algorithms and you know the reason
is that it seems like there's like a
whole huge space of ways you might try
to interact with the database that don't
fit into this framework of learning
where we almost throw the database out
completely and kind of reconstruct it
using very limited access so they're
just a few cases I know of where you can
actually get better results not by going
through this approach one of them is
this work with Justin and Selena showed
is that basically you don't need to do
any of this multiplicative weight stuff
you just you have the database you write
down the polynomial and you perturb its
coefficients and this actually lets you
run in time sub linear in the number of
queries and also this very new result by
Cynthia Sasha and Cronulla we're just
using sort of you know completely
different techniques i would i would
imagine I mean they at least seem very
completely different you get interesting
algorithms that you know can't be
matched by any sort of learning
theoretic technique so I just think that
you know it's really good to be aware of
these these sort of learning techniques
because they seem to give powerful
results and we're very important
kind of showing the power of private
algorithms but you know I really want to
sort of by shedding some doubt as to
whether this is really like always the
right set of techniques so maybe a down
note to end on but like I sort of want
to you know say it's good to keep these
in mind but you know don't get like
locked in on them so you just summarize
basically you know what I gave you with
some sort of flexible very modular
framework for designing differentially
private query release algorithms using
learning theoretic techniques and this
sort of mostly captures like interesting
special cases we know mostly captures
the interesting query release algorithms
we know and you know I think a really
good thing to think about is sort of
what's the limit of these techniques
what you know what are like extra ways
of strengthening the techniques what are
different techniques what are ways of
relaxing the problem do different
techniques and learning give you
stronger things so hopefully by being
aware of you know what people have done
with this you can start applying kind of
new you know going beyond what's already
been done in or out of this framework
yes so if size is not to but it's larger
than what is the dependence on a disease
so are you talking just general query
release or okay so in general i mean i
can always treat the alphabet is binary
and you know if my symbols were from
some alphabet Sigma replace it with like
log Sigma bits so but that yeah so in
general you pay a sort of log of the
alphabet size if you're talking about
particular families of queries they may
you know look simple when viewed on
symbols from a large alphabet but less
simple and viewed as bits so you might
you know make the problem a lot like it
might not be the there might not be a
simple like trade-off like if you wanted
to do sort of conjunctions over a large
alphabet blowing it up to binary like
might make the
harder so then I don't know what ya
better oh wow Adam already made me show
a third know so I mean so the lower
bound that we were able to show it so if
I want to get a you know small weight
like polynomial all anomie Lindy this is
like the best degree you can get size of
the feature space yeah so I don't know I
mean I don't know any Justin you any
like non-trivial lower bound on the
feature space says right so I mean
there's sort of a lower bound that
applies for like any weight but I don't
know like why I don't know anything I
mean it's a good question potentially
you can get like you know much better
algorithms this way it justice talky cut
he was talking about how in a case where
the date though the path of a histogram
side the possible data entries is large
but the number of queries your continues
relatively small yeah push all the
hardness into just an optimism yeah is
there a if you're in a setting where
maybe you have both being large why do
you care about all marginals right but
you also big days is there any zero hope
to through some other means maybe push
everything into suppose that we imagine
that you know we've got good heuristics
for empty or a problem so we can just
push it into that sort of a thing maybe
we can
right um um I mean I can I don't have a
very useful answer to the question of
course it's possible it's sort of a
recent you know thing that Justin
everyone figured out how to push one of
them into a nice compact problem but I I
mean I don't have like you know any
particular candidate for a good solution
but it's it's a good question i mean
okay i just gave lower bounds that are
for worst-case problems but you know
what are some nice ways what are like
good your wrist Ock's for solving the
problem and in particular you need kind
of compact formulations of the problems
it's big question
right so it can think of ways to write
it in a sort of like sampling problems
over both of these large sets which in
principle can be done you know sometimes
I can get three good say you want to
solve for approximate minimax off those
tracks yeah yeah exactly both ways I
guess we just sort of need is kind of a
problem good best response yeah exactly
side somehow exactly so you need you
sort of need both um but in general like
best response right in principle ads
definitely write them as like sampling
the best row and sampling the best query
which is a compact problem even though
it's a hard sorry I got a little like
isolated over here